stop calling people cringe and let them
enjoy what they want to do rude
i mean like you want to role play as a
pregnant pig you know go yeah you know
do you do you
[Music]
minecraft roleplay is cringe
three
two
one
go
i've done a little bit of role playing
in my in my time so i feel like it
wouldn't be right for me to say it's
cringe but um you know you got the
couple of oddballs out there i will be
honest but the majority of it is
overlooked usually it's not that bad
yeah i i agree there's always going to
be like bad role play but since
minecraft is like a game that you could
do anything you can make some really
good role play out of it what i just
want to say is stop calling people
cringe and let them enjoy what they want
to
do true i mean like you want to role
play as a pregnant pig you know
yeah you know do you do you
there's a lot of minecraft role play
that i would say like yeah if i saw it i
think yeah this isn't something i would
want to watch and i might not find it to
my liking which is why i'm like in the
middle but guys it's like some of it i
might like some of it i might not yeah i
agree with that and i was also like
thinking when we do our own type of role
play and like the dream smp there are
definitely times when i felt a little
bit cringe where i didn't know like what
to do or i you know just because i
haven't done it much before so that's
kind of why i'm in the middle but i
really do i do really like doing it but
there are times where i kind of felt a
little bit cringe creating content has
affected my mental health
three
two
one
go
definitely when you're making content
there's a level of expectation that not
only you but other people have on you so
then that could affect your mental
health definitely i think whenever you
know anything is like you know when you
make something a source of income
obviously it's going to have an effect
on you mentally anyway yeah i totally
agree with what you're saying about and
i also want to add that it's not just
that but it's also a lot of us kind of
fall into this out of luck or out of any
other reason very young and no one will
explain to us how for example to do
taxes or how to all of a sudden handle
so many people looking at us or you know
all of these things that you you didn't
learn or no one told you and no one will
minecraft content is getting repetitive
three
two
one
go
it's interesting because there are some
video concepts that are like making a
resurgence and coming back that i've
seen like years ago and so you'll see it
like years ago and then it's like oh my
goodness why is this like video coming
back so that's why part of me wanted to
go and agree but there's also like every
day it's like someone's coming up with a
new idea yeah i think youtube rewards
you for doing like really repetitive
content you can make thousands of
minecraft butt videos and get rewarded
for it and i think that's why a lot of
youtubers do it i think from my
perspective at least minecraft is
literally just a tool for creation it's
not even seen as a game because you can
do so much within it and i feel like
especially on youtube it has the
potential to transcend minecraft as a
game itself so i think there's still
loads of fresh content to be made
i spend more time in minecraft than irl
three
two
one
go
i used to just play like eight hours a
day just literally i would grind it like
how league players grind it i would just
play it like i'd play competitively so i
i would have to just play a lot in order
for me to be good so i'd have this
standard for myself and now like my my
competitiveness is through my work so
for me to maintain my competitiveness in
the game i have to just keep playing
yeah harvey i i used to be the same way
i used to play eight hours a day for
like four years straight just because
that was my content back then you know
the competitive stuff yeah like uhc
right yeah uhc and i felt like that was
the only way to get better and to make
my content better i would have to be
better and i'd have to do like the next
best thing you know what i mean now it's
definitely a lot better so that's why
i'm somewhere in the middle but in the
past i would have been at the very left
line when i uh did a lot of pvp content
back in the day i definitely was more
open that camp but now that it's mostly
like streaming hanging out on my
friend's streams you know recording
videos with my friends and things like
that it's definitely a lot less grindy
because you definitely do have to grind
if you're trying to like you know get
good at pvp and things like that i could
be where harvey is standing and i'd also
be here i slightly disagree because like
at the moment i generally don't um like
i'll play for you know an hour to a day
maybe like sometimes i'll maybe play for
six hours other stuff like literally
none so i've tried to i try to i try to
limit it now
the minecraft player base is dominated
by guys three
two
one
go
especially this year i feel like i've
seen so many girls join the community
and be a part of the gaming community in
the minecraft community especially
especially in the dream smp community
you can see it all over twitter all over
tik tok there's so many girls that maybe
just got into it this year or have been
in the community and they were maybe too
afraid to say that they were i think i
think it's definitely like 50 50. so
yeah if we're talking about the people
who consume minecraft content gaming
content on youtube used to be
predominantly consumed by guys but now i
think you've seen the gender disparity
has definitely gone more towards the
middle and on some platforms you know
like twitter twitch it's gone the other
way it's one of those things where it
very much is dependent on the platform
as to whether you're gonna have more men
or women on it but i definitely would
say that the minecraft community overall
it probably used to be more dominated by
guys and that more guys played it but
now i think it's definitely a lot closer
to the middle yeah i disagree with the
bats like if you asked me like five
years ago or like maybe like two or
three years ago like i would be all the
way over there just based on like my
experience like who i interacted with
and saw in the community like i would
definitely say it was dominating but
guys but like i just looked at my
youtube analytics and it's like 70
female and 30 male so like i think you
know more recently it's definitely
evened out a lot more i wouldn't say
necessarily dominated one way or the
other
i actually enjoy minecraft three
two
one
go
you know there's different phases for me
and enjoying the game but right now it's
just more of like a content thing i like
making the content for the game that's
fun to me but you know i don't hop on
survival mode in my free time and start
playing because it's just gone kind of
old to me that's why i like making
content for it though cause it spices it
up i've been playing minecraft for a
while too but i never played it much i
also definitely enjoy playing other
things more in my free time but i enjoy
it a lot for the things that i am doing
currently i enjoy playing it on my
streams and on videos but just for the
fact i've been playing it for eight
years i haven't played minecraft offline
in a survivable server in probably six
years on my own time on my own server i
feel like i've done everything that can
possibly be done and i'd rather you know
play something else in my free time so i
could save that content for my stream or
for a video so it's more fun when it's
actually happening in like real time i
think that's a good point i do enjoy
minecraft doesn't mean there's not
things about it that i've gotten like
bored with because i have i've always
found there's something else i can go
and do in the meantime you know instead
or try something different but you said
something interesting and i think i'll
move a teeny bit more here there have
been things that you know i'm like i
really want to go and try this thing in
minecraft then i'm like oh no wait i
shouldn't because if i do this on like a
stream or something you're in my content
my audience will enjoy it more if i'm
seeing it for the first time too so uh
that has hindered the enjoyment somewhat
by trying not really being able to try
some of the really cool stuff like off
stream in my free time before i like
show my audience at first like i've been
playing minecraft for about maybe eight
or nine years at this point i've always
consistently been just doing something
else i haven't been doing like the same
exact like i don't know for example play
minecraft survival for like nine years
straight or whatever i've i've just
changed up the type of things i would do
in the game for it to be refreshing and
for me to enjoy it whether it would be
like pvp speedrun servers or whatever
i'd enjoy minecraft but i'll do
different things in minecraft
[Music]
you